hey there everyone i've got something to
show you
that's been almost a year in the making
i've just received it today
i'm a little bit excited let me grab it
here it is
this
is a printed tartan
based on the fibonacci sequence
and if that doesn't excite you
well you're probably watching the wrong
youtube channel there it is
and if that's not good enough
i also have a ribbon of the same design
fibonacci tartan
ribbon so i'm not going to bore you with
wafts and warps and all the terminology
of tartan or plaid as i think people in
the u.s might call it
but basically it's a very number based
thing to make
and the rows and the threads that have
been used to create this design are
based on the fibonacci sequence so we've
got
5 8
89 and i must say it's pretty impressive
i'm really pleased with it so i'm going
to give you a closer look but while i do
i'm going to play a piece of music from
our favorite musician here at
numberphile alan stewart who's been
making all sorts of bits of music for us
lately and he's actually composed a
piece of bagpipes music
based on the fibonacci sequence and this
is properly based on the fibonacci
sequence in lots of different ways so
when you're listening to it see how many
of them you can identify if you don't
like bagpipes i would suggest skipping
in fact i'll tell you exactly how much
to skip
basically
skip one minute and 30 seconds because
that's how long this is going to play
for but it is very cool
it was a bit of an effort to have this
made at times it felt like a battle of
braveheart proportions
but i do want to thank the house of
tartan who are the people who finally
got this done for me and if you want to
design your own pattern or buy tartan or
find out more about it i strongly
suggest their website of course also
thanks to alan for his piece of music
we'll have more about that soon so see
how much fibonacci you are saw in there
and we'll come back to it you're
probably wondering what i'm going to do
with this and i'm wondering the same to
be honest i've got a few ideas a few
ways i might be able to share it with
you guys the viewers but if you've got
any suggestions it's not too late to put
something underneath the video
and i'll be back soon with more
information
one last thank you and that's the people
at audible.com for supporting this
number file video
and actually they've got an offer at the
moment if you're in the us or canada
where if you go to
audible.com numberphile you can download
one of their 100 000 audio books for
free
i was having a look through thinking
what one should i recommend should it be
some scottish poetry or something like
that but then i saw that they have
alex's adventures in numberland
alex bellos you may have seen in some of
our earlier number five videos and he's
got a brilliant book about numbers so go
along audible.com
numberphile go for your free book so
thanks again to everyone at audible.com
because
they let people like me do crazy things
like
make fibonacci tartans
i do like it